("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
("Fireworks" by JMKM)
- [Gary] Yo, man.
- Hi, how are you?
- Good, man.
How are you?
- Good, good to meet you.
- [Gary] Real pleasure.
How are things?
- I appreciate your
time and I know Casey
kind of forced you into this.
- Hey, I've got a
quick fitness thing for you.
- Go ahead.
- Doesn't look anything like me.
- Here's the premise
I'll tell it as it is.
It's called Switch is
the name of the class.
10 minutes yoga
at the beginning,
10 minute stretch at the end,
40 minutes in-between.
In 40 minutes you do
20 different exercises,
each one for two minutes
and then he yells, "Switch."
- He mentioned that.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- He's awesome.
He's been coming to the classes
and bringing all his crazy
people with him so.
- Why don't you guys take over
since I'm logistically incapable
and work with Andy and maybe
in two or three weeks we'll go
'cause I know I've got
a lot of travel coming up.
- Get Ty, Alex.
- Yeah, get Ty,
Alex, like I said get
everybody who's
been talking shit.
Let's see where everybody's at.
Very cool.
So you've always been into
fitness and you always try to
come up with concepts.
- I was special forces military.
I went to college.
I was a lieutenant and
I finished the
military as a lieutenant.
I rewrote the induction program
for new recruits coming in and
then I went to college
in the sports admin degree,
moved to L.A. I worked in
industry there and I trained all
the new, I'm sure
you've all seen "Jurassic Park",
I trained all the dinosaurs
guys for the suits that were.
- [Gary] Oh, that's cool.
Alright, let's do this.
I got to run to another thing.
I'm looking
forward to seeing you.
I'll see you in a couple weeks.
- Yeah, I look forward to it.
Nice to see you.
Nice to see you, too.
- [Kirk] I'm Kirk.
- [Gary] Kirk, pleasure.
Hi. Hey there, how are you?
- Thank you for doing this.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Robert.
- [Gary] Robert, how are you?
- [Robert] Hi, Gary.
- [Woman] For you, and
you have whole approval on
editing before we go live.
- Approved.
- [Woman 2] Okay.
- [Robert] We're going
live right now though.
- Done. I live on the record.
I'm Gary Vaynerchuk
the CEO of VaynerMedia.
There is no concern about the
fact that a lot of people do
want to work and
play at the same time.
Everybody talks about their
work-life balance of Millenials.
Millenials are working
harder than we did.
Our world ended at 6 P.M.
We went home.
Millenials are working
at 7 P.M., 8 P.M., 9 P.M.
and having all of the other
luxuries that are gonna surround
this entire process
is a very big deal to me.
The idea that an
employee that's hustling,
a Millennial who works, can
go at 7:30 to one of the best
restaurateurs in the
world and sit there and work
is an very
important environment.
And when you look at the
Facebooks and the Googles of the
world the way they really
create their campuses are really
intended to maximize results.
For me, VaynerMedia is not of
the size of Facebook and Google.
Neither is SAP and
Boston Consulting and L'Oreal
and Coach and Time Warner.
I mean we're talking about the
biggest companies in the world
that have these campuses.
Well, for me, Hudson Yards
becomes that campus.
We don't own all of it.
It's not all of ours but in the
collective I now can check off
all the boxes that allows me to
be competitive to get the best
talent in the world and to
me when I think about that,
that's the punchline.
When anybody watching right
now, that's the punchline.
If you're a CFO, CEO,
board member decision maker,
that's the punchline.
Who do you think
you're competing with?
How are you gonna win?
It's a talent game.
Awesome.
- [Woman] Appreciate it.
- [Gary] Such a pleasure.
- Thanks so much.
- [Gary] Nice to see you.
- [Woman 2] Great to
see you, thank you.
Perfect.
- [Andy] My name
is Andy Krainak,
I'm brand director
for the man GaryVee.
I've worked for Gary
for over three years now.
I woke up one morning,
I saw Gary tweet,
"What can I do for you?"
And I clicked on the tweet
and saw people responding and
someone said, "I'm hungry,"
and Gary had said,
"Give me your phone number, I'm
gonna send you a cheeseburger."
Like 10 minutes later this
guy tweeted back a photo that a
cheeseburger had
arrived at his house.
I was like damn this guy Gary's
like really doing these things.
So I immediately
just tweeted back at him,
"a chance to work free".
He responded
right back, "Details?"
I responded I'm just looking for
an opportunity to prove myself
and I'm willing
to do it for free. So we--
- [Gary] And we should
also do it going forward,
'cause how many
answers do we have there.
So we're basically on episode
150 so we basically have 100
more episodes five questions
each so it's like 500 videos.
I'm just not getting as much
output as I want in everything.
So I want to make sure I talk
to both of you about what the
current plan is and what some of
the tweaks that I had and that
we'll go through it.
- [Andy] One night, I was
laying in bed at midnight.
I see an email come in it
says from Gary Vaynerchuk.
It said, "Where can you live?
"How little are you
willing to work for?"
I responded I can live
in New York City and I said
I could work for free.
He cc'd Nate who was his
assistant at the time and said,
"Nate, I like this kid.
Maybe he interns for the book."
I interned for Gary for give
months so I joined his team full
time about two years ago and
then I've now since become his
brand director for
about a year and half,
two years and
it's quite the ride.
But so like the French
thing, if we can get 10,
15 videos in French,
having the BSUs is how--
- Hold on, Andy.
Sid, I know you're doing
all the international
stuff, we're captioning.
What language are we missing?
- [Sid] Arabic.
- So, I can tag
you Arabic translators.
The punchline is my
videos translated in Arabic.
Who wants that internship?
Alright, what's your,
what's your Instagram?
- @AlternateTheory.
- (laughs) What?
(group laughter)
Sid's fired. Next person.
Next! (group laughter)
What is it?
- [Andy] He's trying to
decide if he wanted to plug,
yeah, @AlternateTheory.
- @AlternateTheory.
- [Gary] That's your personal.
- That's the one I use for--
- [Gary] Business?
- anyone I talk to.
The other one's just like,--
- This one?
- Yeah, that's me.
- Alright.
- We have a running
joke that DRock does
everything on this team.
And DRock's
amazing and he's very,
very skilled and we love him
very much but there's a lot more
to the man that's GaryVee that's
helping him run his day-to-day
than just David Rock.
Such as Tyler Babin who
edits most of the DailyVees
that you've been seeing.
Tyler Schmitt who
handles all his meetings,
his emails, his inbox and also
he has a business development
guy Alex De Simone.
He has a designer,
he has myself,
he has Eliot who
helps with Instagram.
He has a lot of amazing players
and when you have nine people
trying to work on one brand
and that one brand is a person,
how can we coalesce and
come together and support the
initiatives that Gary wants?
- So I think we
wanted to grab you,
I think it stems from a little
bit of what we talked about last
week over email--
- [Gary] Yep.
- but I think the larger
question is that the three of us
kind of end up brainstorming and
coming up with ideas a lot about
internal communication/culture
and the question was where and
how much do you
want to be involved in
things that we create?
And then, I think, it really got
heightened because of what we
talked about
last week and a lot,
that's just a lot of
what's going on in the air--
- [Gary] Makes sense.
- right now, so.
- The most.
- [Sam] Yeah.
- Because I think that's the
thing that's most probably
populated to a lot of minds
which is I just don't think I'm
as aligned with what is
the obvious way to do this.
- [Sam] Mhmmm.
- And I think we
should all get aligned.
I think it's a
DNA thing for anybody,
you know, I think everything has
rewards and everything has
pros and cons to every situation.
I think this is a very
imperative game of like
self-awareness and understanding
your appetite for feedback and
your own self-awareness and
empathy is completely maps to
the upside of how much you
can put yourself out there.
- What really just happened is
I tried three different times to
say what the most important
thing I've learned from Gary is
it's like speed,
it's work ethic.
Gary really does work
15, 18 hours a day
which is insane and
he does trump speed
over everything else.
Just fast as possible.
The world is moving we we're
trying to keep up with it but
really it's empathy.
Gary's intuition and the way
he understands people and can
relate to them is
why he's so successful.
- I'm a vlogger and I
mean I don't have a DRock,
I am my own DRock.
- [Gary] You don't have this.
- Hi DRock. (laughs)
- [DRock] Hi.
- But yeah, you kind of have
multiple revenue streams
which I think is the way to go.
Two years ago only, I was
working a regular 9 to 5 job and
then I was working on my side
hustle which is my vlog and a
few other things and now I'm a
digital nomad kind of doing my
own thing and
traveling and that.
- [Gary] Yep.
- [Woman 3] I think I do a
decent job at balancing it all
out but how do I make sure that
I'm giving the same about of
love to all my different
little projects and ventures?
- By not crippling yourself and
thinking that you need to give
the same amount of
love at all times always.
People are too worried about the
micro and they think that if you
have like four projects
you have to give them
all 25% every single day.
The reality is I was just
sitting here right now with my
team some things, right now
Wine Library is
getting zero love. Right?
Sometimes my personal
brand is getting love.
Sometimes VaynerMedia's
getting love.
I think it's you need to be
careful on not trying to be
balanced at all times.
You just need to be balanced in
the macro or you need to map to
the ambition
that you have for it.
So, you know, if
four different projects,
if you gave them a percentage of
value to you or upside to you or
how much you like them or
how big you think they can be,
you need to map
your energy that way.
So, if you think this
one thing, the vlogging,
is 80% of your upside, well then
you need to be mapping 80% of
your energy and the
others might be 5, 5 and 10.
- He finishes my sentences
before I'm done speaking and he
does it, you can deploy
empathy in every way.
Whether it's trying
to help your coworker,
trying to understand where
they're coming from or
trying to make a million
dollars on a business pitch.
If you can put yourself in
that other person's shoes--
- The reason I can put myself
out there so much is I'm so in a
great spot on those pillars and
that's the ultimate blessing in
life and I'm very empathetic
that most people don't come with
that level of balance
of ego and humility and
I think that's what it takes.
However balanced you are with
ego and humility will play out
itself in the public eye and
so I think that's why I've been
able to navigate because I think
I'm the best and I think I mean
nothing and I'm just
empathetic to people's feedback.
I'm also self-aware
like I curse,
I'm quite confident in the shit
I talk about which will turn
people off especially
if they have no context.
I don't expect
them to have context.
People always
come up to me and say,
"I'm sorry I didn't
know who you were."
I was like, "I don't
think 99.9% of the world
"doesn't know who I am."
So, I think the
answer to that question,
I think much to why I have a
good feel of Gaga and know
her backstory and
people around her.
She's in a good spot.
She can handle that pretty well
because she's internal and
I think if you have your
self-worth wrapped up in others
opinions it's a very difficult
game to play or you play 'til
the level of where
your appetite goes.
Too many people cripple
themselves on finding that
balance and they're doing it
in a micro instead of a macro.
- [Woman 3] Yeah, I was gonna
try to think of them as my kids
and give the same
amount of love but maybe not.
- [Gary] Nobody ever
gives their kids the same
amount of love in a micro.
It's just not the way it
happens and even in a macro it's
probably inconceivable
and so, you know,
sometimes you have to worry
about the kid that's got an
issue or sometimes you got
to worry about the kid that's
excelling and so that's just
the way works and the middle kid
never gets any love.
I mean the whole thing.
I go through moments where it's
better than it's worse then it's
good like again
I just think everybody's
overthinking the day-to-day.
You need to think
of this in years terms
instead of days terms.
("Fireworks" by JMKM)